اكد جيش النيجر تمسكه بالاطاحه بالرئيس
محمد بازوم وتوعد بالتصدي للتدخل العسكري
الذي هددت مجموعه ايكواس بتنفيذه اذا لم
يتراجع الانقلابيون عن اجراءاتهم قبل يوم
الاحد وكانت اكواس اكدت انها وضعت خطه
لتدخل عسكري في النيجر دعمته باريس ورفضت
تشاد المشاركه فيه من ناحيتها دعت الجزائر
لحل مشكله ما سمته الانقلاب عن طريق
الحوار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى جديه الخطه
التي اعدتها اكواس بالتدخل العسكري في
النيجر وما خياراتها لتنفيذ تهديدها
والنتائج التي قد تترتب على هذه الخطوه ما
امكانيه استجابه القاده العسكريين في
النيجر للمهله الممنوحه لهم وما خياراتهم
لمواجهه الضغوط الاقليميه والدوليه التي
يتعرضون لها كيف ستتعامل دول جوار النيجر
الاخرى مع خيار التدخل العسكري الذي تلوح
به اكواس وما فرص نجاح دعوتها لانتاج
الدبلوماسيه من اجل حل الازمه
[موسيقى]
قبل ساعات من انتهاء مهله مدتها اسبوع
منحتها المجموعه الاقتصاديه للدول غرب
افريقيا الانقلاب في النيجر من اجل
التراجع عنه حسم مصدر عسكري في نيابه
للجزيره موقف الجيش من هذا التهديد وقال
انه لن يرضخ لها مفوض الذي قال ان
المجموعه تسعى لوضع حد لانقلابات في
المنطقه وجعل النيجر عبره لمن سواها في
هذا الصدد اكد ان قاده اركان الجيوش
المجموعه وضعوا خطه لتدخل عسكري محتمل في
النيجر وان اقرار العمليه وتوقيتها متروك
لرؤساء دول المجموعه لكن المفوض الذي تحدث
بعد اجتماع رفع فيه قاده اركان دول اكواس
توصياتهم لقاده بلدانهم اكد رغبه المجموعه
في نجاح الدبلوماسيه في حل الازمه في
النيجر وان تمنح قاده الانقلاب كل الفرص
للتراجع
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين كولو نقلت
ان التهديد باللجوء الى التدخل العسكري في
النيجر يجب ان يؤخذ على محمل الجده واضافت
ان امام الانقلابيين مهله حتى الاحد لوقف
ما سمتها المغامره واعاده الديمقراطيه كما
جددت كلونا دعم فرنسا الكامل للرئيس محمد
بازوم وحكومته وقالت انهما يمثلان السلطه
الشرعيه الوحيده في النيجر واضافت وزيره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه ان باريس تدعم جهود
اكواس لاحباط محاوله الانقلاب في النيجر
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى ادريس الاكاديمي
والمحلل السياسي النيجري
وينضم الينا ايضا من باريس لبارين مديره
معهد دراسات العلاقات الدوليه
والاستراتيجيه في باريس
ابدا منك اذا
ابدا من ضيفنا
المحلل النيجري واسالك وهو السيد ادريس
ايت ابدا منك لاسال ما برايك ما مدى
جديه هذا الاستعداد للتدخل او كيف تعتقد
انه ينظر اليه في النيجر من قبل
الانقلابيين او من قبل سلطه الانقلاب
تحيه طيبه لك استاذ وتهيه خاصه قناه
الجزيره والمشاهدين الكرام الحقيقه ان
التفاعل مع هذه البيانات والتحديدات التي
صدرت من المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا
اخذ على مهمل الجد لكن هذا من جانب الشعب
اما من جانب الانكلابيين باعتبارهم
النيجر دوله اذن في المنظمه قبل الائتمان
الاخير الذي لم يدعى اليه بعد الانقلاب
اعتقد ان الانقلابيين كانت مخاوفهم منصبه
فيما يتعلق بالجاره النيجيريا وهي اكبر
دوله والدوره ايضا دوله قوه من حيث مؤشر
القوه العالميه او
العالمي لكن هذا المساء
قرر مجلس الشيوخ النيجيري
الرفض اطار تفويدا للرئيس النيجيري بولاتي
نوبل للتدخل في جمهوريه النيجر الان قبل
ان اصل الى هذه المقابله كانت التفاعلات
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وكذلك
المجموعات الخاصه كلها بدات تستبشر بان من
دون نيره لا يوجد هناك تدخل خارجيا او
خاصه تداخلاص من الدول الاخرى كلها ليست
هذه للنيجر باكسي وجموله بين لا يمكن ان
تخاطر لوحدها او حتى ما السنغال والساحل
الدول الحارثه جدا على التدخل العسكري ومن
الدوله الفرنكفونيه باختلاف نيجيري هي
الدوله انجولفونيه وهذا يفسر على
الجهه الثانيه او للطرف الاخر بانه دليل
على ان نيجيريا هي الديمقراطيه الحكه من
دول ايكو اس باعتبار انه قرار التدخل سئل
او طلب من مجلس شيوخها الممثل للشعب
التدخل والرفض بينما راينا الدول
الفرانكفونيه التي تعتبر دمى لدى فرنسا او
هكذا يقال بين قوسين
ابدت استدادا لارسال جيوشها وبعدهم ابدت
طائراتها ارسلت طائرات اوليه لوزاره
دفاعها نحو
العاصمه النيجيريه ما يفسر ان هذا التدخل
يعتبر ان يدا فرنسيا وراءها او وراء قوه
لان اي تراجع سيفسر على انه
اعتراف بالدف من المجموعه الاقتصاديه لكن
ما عدا مخيفا كما كان في البدايات لما
كانت النيجيريا مصممه على التدخل العسكري
الى يعني كيف يمكن ان يكون الدور الفرنسي
في هذا التدخل العسكري وما موقفه باريس
منه
حسنا في الوقت الراهن فرنسا تواصل تبني
موقف
متشدد ضد الانقلابيين
وهي تختفي وراء مجموعه الاقتصاديه للدول
الغربيه واذا لم تتمكن من التدخل بعد
الاعتراض مجلس الشيوخ
النيجيري فان ذلك سيكون معقدا بالفعل
مثلما تفضل ضيفكم اذا من الصعب في الواقع
الحديث عن هذا السيناريو لان هنالك
اجراءات مختلفه
هنالك معلومات
متضاربه تاتي من هذا الطرف ومن ذاك
معلومات تدعو الى التدخل العسكري واخرى
تقول انه بالامكان الوصول الى حل
الدبلوماسي اذا نرى ربما بعض التراجع بسبب
موقف مجلس الشيوخ في نيجيريا هنالك كذلك
البنين التي فتحت حدودها مع النيجر وهو
خبر مهم جدا هنالك كذلك موقف الدول
التي ليست من مجموعه افريقيا الغربيه
مثلما موقف موريتانيا موقف الجزائر وموقف
التشاد التي تندد هذا الانقلاب ولكنها
ليست متفقه مع تدخل العسكري هنالك كذلك
برلمانات
افريقيا الغربيه السنغال وكوت
التي الدول التي في دستورها ماده تمنع
الدخول في حرب بدون اذن من مجلس النواب هل
سيتم تجاوز البرلمانات هل سيكون ذلك
دستوريا الا يكون ذلك متناقض مع مبدا من
مبادئ الديمقراطيه كل هذه الامور تجعل
الوضع في هذا
المساء يتجه الى التراجع ان التدخل
العسكري
هو طبعا رئيس وزراء النيجر وهو موالي
للرئيس بازون يقول ان المساعي مستمره
للتوصل لحل دبلوماسي ولكن حتى الان لم يكن
هناك اي رد من طرف قاده الانقلاب ينضم
الينا الان البخاري محمد مؤمل الخبير
العسكري خبير في الشؤون العسكريه والامنيه
سيد محمد مؤمل برايك ما هي احتمالات ان
يكون هناك تدخل عسكري حقيقي من النيجر في
الوقت الذي كانت تقول فيه ضيفتنا من باريس
ليبارين ان هذا قد لا يكون سهلا بسبب
عوائق تتعلق بالمجالس
البرلمانيه التشريعيه في هذه البلدان التي
قد لا تسمح لها بان تتوجه لتدخل عسكري في
النيجر
انا اعتقد بان مجموعه الكواس اتخذت قرارا
متسرعا نوعا ما لانه خطير جدا ومن الصعب
تطبيقه ومن الصعب ايضا الرجوع عنه لذلك
الوضعيه اشكاليه عويصه التدخل من الصعب
والرجوع عنه ايضا اصعب لذلك انا اعتقد بان
سيكون هناك تحضيرات عسكريه
جديه
وتظهر بشكل يوحي بان احتمال التدخل يبقى
دائما قائما في الوقت الذي ينبغي ان يكون
فيه مفاوضات موازيه لها لان مصداقيه
المفاوض ينالها من
احتماليه التدخل
وقوته والعكس صحيح انا اعتقد بان نيجيريا
سوف تلعب على الوتيرتين وكذلك الطرف الاخر
يعني الانقلابيين في مفارقه كلما تحددت
نيجيريا واعوانها عن التدخل وحضروه شكل
ذلك فعلا ضغطا ولكنه بالمقابل يستخدمه
الطرف الاخر لتسجيل لتجييش مشاعر الوطنيه
لدى الناس المحليين والسكان في النيجر
وعلى العموم المواطنون محليون سواء
بالنيجر وسواء في البلدان الافريقيه
الاخرى مناوه لتدخلات الاجنبيه خاصه عندما
بان الغرب طالع بها وخصوصا فرنسيه
قلت انه من الصعب تطبيقه ومن الصعب
التراجع عنه ونتحدث عن هذا القرار بالتدخل
العسكري سؤالي لك خبير عسكري لماذا من
الصعب تطبيقه هو نعلم ان نيجيريا فقط على
سبيل المثال قواتها
22 مره
يعني 22 ضعف عدد قوات النيجر التي تبلغ
نحو
عشره الاف تقريبا
بان اعلان الحرب امر صعب جدا نظرا لا ما
يحيط به من التساؤلات من
عدم اليقين لانه يتولد عنه كثير من الامور
ثانيا من الناحيه السياسي وهذه هي المعضله
الكبرى الناحيه البعد الكبرى هي
الناحيه السياسيه
وحتان جريها ان كانت لازم تتدخل بقوتها هي
الاخرى تعاني اكراهات شديده لان فيها عدم
استقرار الامن داخلي الحرب ضد حرام والحرب
حتى ضد الطوائف القبليه فيما بينها وجيشها
منها كل حد ما ولا ينبغي لها
ان تعتمد على الخارج خاصه الدول الغ
ربيه لا يمكنها ان تظهر فظهورها بالعمليه
سيكون سلاحا سياسيا للانقلابيين
والمواطنهم
سيده فارين عندما تقول وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه انه يجب التعامل بجديه مع
تهديدات الاكواس بالتدخل العسكري فما الذي
نفهمه من هذا عن الموقف الفرنسي وعن
احتمال ان تكون فرنسا مستعده
للدعم حتى عسكريا بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر
حسنا انا اعتقد ان فرنسا تواصل شد الذراع
في هذه المساله ولكن اذا ما قررت دول
الغرب افريقيا عدم المشاركه
فانه سيكون هنالك مظاهرات ضد فرنسا في
كامل المنطقه
وفي
الوقت الرهن واستعراض للعضلات من قبل
فرنسا
لانها لا يمكنها المواصله في هذا الموقف
المتشدد طويلا هنالك كذلك موقف اخر وهي
محاوله اعاده محمد بازون الى
وظائفه فرنسا في هاته الحاله
تغامر مع تراجع الدول الغرب افريقيا وربما
ستجد فرنسا معزوله في هذه الحاله
حسنا سيدي يوسف ايه هل تعتقد ان قاده
الانقلاب قد يتراجعون في نهايه المطاف
بسبب التهديد بتدخل عسكري من دول الاكواس
لا لا اعتقد ذلك يتلاقن وكما كررت اكثر من
مره
الجيش الانقلاب في النيجر وصل الى نقطه
اللانهايه وباعتبار ان الشعب التف حوله
يجد هذه الورقه
الرابحه في يدها استخدامها في احتمال اي
تدخل عسكري او حتى الضغوطات الخارجيه
وخاصه الغربيه باعتبار انه الروايه
السرديه
المتردده والتي تلقى دعما كبيرا لوسات
الشعب ان فرنسا ملتزمه بالنظام وليس
جمهوريه النيجر كدوله والنظام باعتباره
متمسكه به
ويحقق لها مصاريها في المشاريع الاقتصاديه
والجزراتيجيه في جمهوريه النيجر وهذا الذي
يفسر اذن لا تهمها الديمقراطيه ولا
الشرعيه وهذا بالضبط ما يذكر بما حدث مثلا
في فنزويلا وهذا اظن هذه السينار هو الذي
سيتكرر باعتبار ان الرئيس الوزراء
الاسبقوا محمد الذي اجتمع
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كثيرين كولونا
الصور انتشر على نطاق النواسي اذا نحن
امام
حكومتان كما حدث في فنزويلا ما الرئيس
مادوره في 2020 حيث الشعب اعترف به كرئيسا
للجمهوريه بينما دول الغربيه وخاصه
الولايات المتحده اعترفت بخوان جويدو الان
هذه الحاله بالتمام في جمهوريه النيجر
والانتراف من قبل المجلس العسكري لا يزال
قائما في اوساه الشاب حتى الان لا يوجد
هناك جبهه داخليه تناحدها ولا انقلاب
احتمال انشقاق الانقلاب كانشكاك داخل
الجيش الحل المتبقى هو فقط التسعيد فيما
يتعلق به الديكوتات العقوبات الاقتصاديه
نعم طبعا في الاثناء هناك نفوذ وحضور
وكاله السوشيت نقلت عن مسؤولنا عسكري غربي
قوله ان قاده الانقلاب في النيجر طلبوا
المساعده من مجموعه الروسيه الموجوده في
مالي للتعامل مع تدخل العسكري المح تمل
لمجموعه اكواس وذكرت الوكاله ان احد قاده
الانقلاب زارا مالي واجرى اتصالات مع احد
افراد فاجنر وابلغه بحاجه قاده الانقلاب
الى مساعده المجموعه سيد محمد مؤمل الان
فاجنر موجوده يبدو طلبت المساعده
ما اهميه دورها في التصدي لاي تدخل عسكري
في صالح قاده لصالح قاده الانقلاب
انا اعتقد بان
الانقلابيين فعلا
سيلجؤون لاي طلب اخر عسكري
[موسيقى]
يساعدهم ويلعبون على الوتيره الجويه
السياسيه في صراع سياسي العالمي للمنطقه
بين من جهه روسيا ومن جهه اخرى الولايات
المتحده واورنسا والغرب وهم يلعبون على
هذه الوتيره ومن مظاهر هذه الوتيره من
تجليتها استخدام فاغنير في المنطقه
استخدام في المنطقه الحقيقه زائد العسكريه
منهم محدودا نسبيا مقارنه بما
بما تكلفه ولكنها سياسيا سياسيا ورقه يمكن
اللعب عليها وانا اتوقع منهم ايضا ان
يلعبوا على وترات اخرى عن استطاعوا من
تركيا مثل ايران مثل الجزائر وغيرها وكما
قال ض السابق اظنه من النيجر بان
الانقلابيين بلغوا مرحله في التقدم في
مخططهم صار من الصعب جدا عليه ان يتراجعوا
ولكن ايضا هم يعانون ضعفا اخر قويه جدا
وهو الحصار الاقتصادي النيجر يعتمد كثيرا
على
المساعدات الخارجيه وعلى العلاقات
الخارجيه اليوم تحت حصار اقتصادي والدول
التي تساعده
مالي
واساسا مالي وبوركينا فاسو والى حد ما
ايضا غينيا وربما تشاد هذه الدول امكانيه
الاقتصاديه محدوده وخاصه بان من يحادونه
منها ليست لهم موانئ ليست لهم امكانيه
الاقتصادي مهم وسيدنا نزلي فارين سؤالي لك
هو
تمدد النفوذ الروسي عن طريق فاغنر الى اي
مد ى يمكن ان يجعل فرنسا مهتمه بان تتدخل
عسكريا او يدفعها بهذا الاتجاه كما قلت
بدعم مباشره او غير مباشر وبدعم ايضا من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ونعلم ان هناك
قاعده للطائرات المسيره امريكيه وهناك
1500 جندي فرنسي اضافه الى
يعني الخبره الفرنسيه الطويله بالمنطقه
حسنا لا اريد
السباق لان قد تتغير الامور في هذا المساء
خاصه وان المهله تنتهي غدا فجرا ما اعتقده
اليوم في هذه الساعه ان الامريكيين الذين
دفعوا مجموعه غرب
افريقيا الى التلويح
بالتهديد العسكري
اذا لا اعتقد مره اخرى لان الامريكيين
والفرنسيين
[موسيقى]
سيغامرون في عمليه عسكريه دوليه بهذا
الشكل اذا مات راجعت مجموعه غرب افريقيا
فان فرنسا وامريكا ستتراجع لا اعتقد
انقلبيين يحتاجون الى مساعده فاجنر حتى
وان كان ذلك من ضمن اللعبه السياسيه الجو
السياسيه للتهديد لا اتصور مرتزقت فاجنر
يصلون الى نيجر هم متواجدون في مالي
ولكنهم لا يصنعون الفرق في الحرب على
الارهاب اضافه الى ذلك
هؤلاء المرتزقه يكلفون باهضا والانقلاب
ليس لديهم الاموال الكافيه ولا ارى اي
مصلحه
على الجهود الدبلوماسيه الجهود
الدبلوماسيه المبذوله الانشاد من دول جوار
النيجر التي اكدت انها لن تشارك في اي
تدخل عسكري في النيجر وحثت الشعب هناك على
الحوار والانتباه للمخاطر المحدقه ببلدهم
موقف مشابه هو موقف الجزائر الذي دعا التي
دعا رئيسها عبد المجيد تبون الى حل الازمه
القائمه في النيجر بالطرق السلميه واعتبر
ما حدث في النيجر انقلابا ودع قادته
للعوده الى الشرعيه الدستوريه
السيد يوسف سيد ادريس ايه
هل تعتقد ان جهود
تشاد والجزائر يمكن ان تنجح هل تعتقد ان
حل دبلوماسي يمكن ان يتم التوصل اليه
نعم قبل الاجابه على هذا السؤال اريد فقط
ان ننوه الى ان ما نشرته اساسيته
اقاله الانقلاب تواصلوا مع مجموعه هذه
معلومه لا اساس لها من نفسها وانا لدي
مراجل موثوقه ولهم علاقه مع المجلس
العسكري نفو هذه المعلومه جمله تفسير ما
حدث انهم تواصلوا مع مالي التي هي لديها
علاقه مع مجموعه اما فيما يتعلق بالجهود
الوساطه اعتقد انه حل الوحيد لانه كانت
الريحانات ان يكون هناك جبهه داخليه وهذا
لم يحصل او يحدث هناك انقلاب ضد الانقلاب
تسانده الدول الغربيه وخاتلا لديها قواعد
عسكريه في النيجر وهذا لم يحدث التدخل
العسكري نرى انها تتقلص يوما بعد يوم
وخاصه بعد نيجيريا اذا يبقى حل التفاوض
واعتقد ان هذا هو الحل المنتظر لكن يبقى
تبقى سياسه الردعه قائمه حتى لا تتشبث
المجلس العسكري او الانكلابيين بالسلطه
لفتره اطول الان الوسط الان الدبلوماسي
الممكن تنفيذه هو فتره انتقاليه قصيره
تكون ثلاثه اشهر او سته اشهر على ان لا
يرجع الحزب الحاكم السابق او النظام
السابق للحكم ولا يبقى الانقلابيون في
السلطه واعتقد ان الجزائر بالتحديد حتى
الان لم تتدخل دبلوماسيا لكن لديها القدره
لتحقيق ذلك اذا ما تعودت ما دول اخرى حتى
اقليميه او دوليه اما جمهوريه تشاد فحتى
الان يفسروا محاوله وسادتها على انها
انقلاب اخر باعتبار ان محمد انقلب للدستور
بعد مقتل والده ادريس ديبي اذا الدوله
التي لديها مصداقيه حتى الان اقليميا قد
تكون نيجيريا الجزائر وربما الى مستوى اقل
ايضا
[تصفيق]
شكرا جزيلا لك ادريس ايه الاكاديميه للمحل
السياسي
النيجري واشكر كذلك البخاري محمد مؤمل
الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه والامنيه وشؤون
الافريقيه ونشكر كذلك اللزلي بارين لمديره
معهد الدراسات العلاقات الدوليه
والاستراتيجيه في باريس المختصه في شؤون
دول منطقه الساحل والصحراء
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج الخبر
شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]